okay just testing the sound is it fine
yeah
so apologies here i i um
i got told i had this talk 10 minutes
ago
so
it's a bit of a rush
um
i was scheduled towards the end of the
day originally
um
okay so the risk five microprocessor so
how many of you um actually have used it
or any familiar with
um
assembly coding
okay it's quite and how many
how many have um used any risk five
before
okay so
that's good
um
so my name is eric enghheim i work for a
company called 60 north we do consulting
work and actually what i normally do is
create educational content for a
programming language called
julia
which is a
new language for
machine learning
data science high performance computing
so that's a bit different from what i'm
going to be talking about here which is
more about sort of a hobby interest of
mine for for a long time i started
programming assembly codes on the
68k
motorola 68000 back in
the late 18
the late 1980s
um on amiga thousand
um not quite that probably long ago so i
tried it different architectures and
i think
risk five is a kind of it's quite
exciting new architecture
to work on
so um
what exactly is risk five so one thing
that is important to keep in mind when
uh
when thinking about risk five is that
it's
unlike x86 and um
arm it's not an architecture that was
primarily made
for industry so those other
architectures
are typically
used by and made for industry
um
risk five in contrast comes out of
university from
berkeley and it's actually the fifth
generation of the very first risk
processor risk one
that was created by a group
um
i'm not sure if he was led by but david
patterson is a pretty important name in
this history he was the one that coined
the term risk reduced instruction set um
computer
so this was back in
1981 and this has been going through
several generations
um
until they got to risk five
um and then with risk five they wanted
to create something that was
usable um
both for academic purposes and also for
industry so it should be something that
you can implement
that gives you high
performance in a realistic setting
but it can also meet goals like
for students who don't want it too
complex architecture that is hard to
learn you want something where
students can realistically implement a
simple risk processor in the first
semester
so for me as a hobbyist this is kind of
an interesting thing with risk five it's
something that if you're interested in
playing around with microprocessors as
on a sort of hobby basis this is a very
interesting architecture to develop
you often see risk 5 pitched as a sort
of linux for
microprocessors and i think that
this is actually a little bit a bad kind
of
characterization for me that was
actually what made me
not care that much about looking at
risk five
uh initially
um because
it sounded like it was just a kind of a
me too microprocessor
where
it was just open source but just did
everything else like um like everybody
else
i think a more important part of risk
five is actually that it's a modular
design which is not common in the
industry
so risk five is composable
extensions unlike what you find with x86
and arm
so i'm going to use a bit of a silly
analogy tear to try to
explain what we mean by that we can
imagine something like
x86 that started back in 1978 with sort
of one menu here you've got 80
instructions
and then customers want more so they're
adding more to this
buffet of instructions and they keep
adding and adding and adding
and so
eventually
they have 1300 instructions
so they've been adding three
instructions roughly
every month since 1978 and actually this
is a low number because this is for
32-bit for 64-bit is around 1500
instructions now
and it isn't actually all that much
better for arm microprocessors
32-bit is about 500 instructions
depending a bit on how you count it
for 64-bit
it's about a thousand
now you can contrast that with risk five
which is just 47 instructions that you
have to implement
just reading the specification would
take you about
six hours
so
what is the difference why so few
instructions not because risk
five is more like a menu you get to
choose
i just want to buy the fries
and the apple cake and you only pay for
that and what do i mean by pay well i
mean in terms of transistors
you're only paying for the features that
you're using and you don't have to pay
for all the other stuff that is
accumulated over time
so these two sheets
let me see if i have this
sheet here
so this is kind of
most of what you need to know about risk
five the instructions here
um
you need a quite a thick book to do that
with x86
um so the first part here this other
standard instructions
that you have to implement and most of
the other stuff here that is those are
just
common extensions
that you don't have to
and why does all this matter was because
complexity costs money
so each of these little squares right is
a chip
and you would think that if i make a
chip that's twice as large
well the cost will increase with twice
i'm having twice as many transistors
but no it actually grows with the square
of the area it's a quadratic
equation and the reason for that is that
you get these random um
[Music]
faults at random points on a chip so if
you have a very
a larger area it's a bigger chance that
there's going to be a flaw in that area
and that's kind of why
it's quite expensive to have large chips
compared to small ones
so if you compare the risk 5 rockets
it's one of the simpler risk fi designs
with an arm cortex a5
and they have kind of similar capability
similar amount of cache memory
you will find that the die size
size of the chips is about half on the
risk 5.
but this translates into a price
that's one fourth
of the arm cortex a5 so that's a big
difference
now you shouldn't exaggerate this
implication because
when you get the desktop style chips
like say the m1
um that apple has released at 16 billion
transistors and a lot of what's on there
has nothing to do with decoding um
instructions it's a lot of other types
of
features so for desktop class chip
the chips that you
the transistors you need for decoding
instructions
is going to be dwarfed by other things
but when you're working in the embedded
space this matters a lot so we can
imagine that uh for embedded type of
hardware maybe low end um phones
you're gonna start seeing risk five
um entering the market because they're
gonna have such a cost advantage
and also for specialized hardware where
you typically want to make for instance
small cores it's hard to make small
course
if you have a lot of instructions
but of course this is for the same
volume right now um you will typically
find that the risk five chips that you
might or boards you might want to buy
those are probably going to be more
expensive than arm simply because
they're not produced in the same volume
but when volumes are equal you're gonna
see the cost advantage
so what are these risk five extensions
well they're given names from adz
and then
that makes you it's easier to kind of
specify the compilers and so on what
architecture you're working on so this
first part here
rv 32 that's risk 5 32 bits could be 64
or even 1828 actually
and then this essay we have the m a
f d extension so
m is multiply and divide this is for
atomic
instructions and so on because this is
kind of a standard set of instructions
that you might want to use for general
purpose operating system such as linux
these are abbreviated to a g so when you
see a g it means sort of the standard
instructions you might want to have on a
sort of desktop class
machine
the way you deal with this at runtime is
that
all risk 5 processors have to implement
this
command status register and where you
have a bunch of special
um
functions that you can read so on the
sheet you have this
section here that explains the
instructions that you can use
to read and check
what extensions does the chip i'm
currently running on actually support
you don't have to necessarily do this it
is practical say
you are doing a lots of matrix
multiplications maybe you're doing
something machine learning task
and then you can check do i have the
vector extension for instance if i have
that i can take a different code path
and i can compute
those
matrix multiplications a lot faster
but you don't necessarily need to set
that up because all the instructions
that are now supported get trapped
so that is sort of like an interrupt you
will jump to somewhere else in the code
in the operating system and you can
simulate those instructions that are not
supported that means that
given you have operating system set up
for this
you can your program can in principle
run on any risk
fire microprocessor regardless of the
extensions that it supports
uh final thing to to note about
sentience is that they're frozen that
means that
once it's been ratified which
instructions are going to be an
extension
and how they're going to work this is
never going to change
so you can't
so this is good for backwards
compatibility right if you've written
code to work with one particular set of
extensions
that's going to continue working for a
long time this is also an important goal
for risk five
when universities use other
instruction sets in the past they found
that
it was
hard for long-term use because they
often have particular instructions
that
really only made sense in that area you
know for particular optimization risk is
particularly risk five is particularly
made
to have a very long-term view that this
architecture should exist for a very
long time
let's contrast this with x86 and x86 and
arm
what if they decided to say arm that we
want to be
competitive with risk five in the sort
of low end um embedded space so we're
gonna cut up our in our huge instruction
set about a thousand instructions into
lots of different extensions like risk
five could they do that well not really
because
you have all this legacy software which
is not written to take that into
consideration so if they reduce a new
chip with
just a few extensions
the existing software wouldn't run right
because it doesn't know
to check any kind of status register so
it will just crash
and you don't have an operating system
existing operating systems are not set
up to to trap and simulate other
instructions
so unlike risk you don't have the risk
five you don't have the um
the ecosystem the tools and the
practices and so on to support this on
risk five there's a
suit of tools to verify that you're
following the specification that you're
checking extensions and so on
now you could do it to the existing
instruction set architectures
but it's not very much value to say okay
we're going to have an extension for
these 20 new instructions and you
already have
1500 instructions that you have to
implement
so just to clarify some of the
the terminology that i used here
um
we gotta separate between instruction
set architecture and the micro
architecture risk five is primarily a
instruction set architecture that's what
it defines that's in it's an open
instruction set architecture and that's
sort of like the interface
to
your microchip whereas the microchip
the micro architecture is how it
actually works internally so as an
example
um
an amd and an intel chip right they can
both run the same code even though they
have completely different micro
architectures and that's because they
have the same instruction set
architecture so the isa
that is what you see as an assembly
programmer or as a compiler writer
so where is risk five used so you can
see there is
um
already a bunch of different kinds of
styles of boards
that exist to use risk five processors
people talk about that with all these
extensions that you can optionally add
and companies can add their own
custom extensions will we just not end
up with this kind of
jungle where with incompatibilities and
a mess
it's important to understand that
that makes
that makes no sense for
if you're making something like more
like a personal computer
but those boards are probably going to
standardize on the g
extensions
but for a lot of other things is
specialized hardware
such as accelerators and you're not
going to be running all sorts of
software on those so compatibility is
not
as important there so
you might still in the future have x86
and
um
arm sort of where that's the main system
but you might have all sorts of
extra hardware accelerators that are
actually risk five processors
another thing where you're starting to
see risk five up here is for the
internet of
things so this is one example
speedmex duino it has neural network
processor machine vision you can connect
cameras and so on
i think this one is quite interesting
this is from esperanto technologies
so they have
this system on a chip this one here 28
billion transistors
and it has
four maxian general purpose
processor risk five 64-bit
um and on these you can run basically
like a linux operating system
um general purpose operating system
and there you can prepare for instance
machine learning tasks um
maybe heavy matrix multiplications
and the maxims can dish that out to
their minions so that's a 1088
course
that each have implemented a a vector
processing instruction set so those are
very
very small um
course
so they are quite simple but they do
want one particular thing very fast like
vector processing and that's why this
manages to have really high performance
100 to 200 um
operations at less than 20 watts
so just these minions 1000 the
1088 i think they are less than 10 watts
um so comparison the m1
that apple released that was about 15
watts i think
so to understand a little bit more of
this kind of technical details i want to
go through i'm going to
go a bit through risk 5
assembly code
if you want to get into this this
cornell risk by simulator is a kind of
easy one to get into it doesn't support
all that many instructions you can see
them down here um you got all the
registers here the code that we're
pasting in and here you can see the code
execute
so
if you're interested in trying this you
can use this link take a photo or that
or something
so what i'm going to go through to try
to explain is this
simple counter program it takes a value
in
the
this x1 register that you will have to
set yourself and then it starts counting
down
the instructions
for
assembly code tends to use these kind of
abbreviated words like
at add i which is add immediate
sw store word
and so on but we're going to go through
these in more detail
you also have in risk five a number of
pseudo instructions
and one of the reasons for that is that
because instruction set is so compressed
and small they try to be clever about it
and so in each instruction can be kind
of used in different ways that can hurt
readability a bit so you have
pseudo instructions without just really
just translates into actual essa
instructions
that kind of convey better what they're
for so this is load immediate which is
actually what you intend with the the
ads that you saw earlier
so
central comp uh
central thing for um microprocessors to
understand is registers and registers is
i think this is kind of interesting from
a historical perspective this is a very
old idea this is an old mechanical
calculator a so-called arithmometer
actually a russian one
and this has three registers here
it works but you're pulling down these
different dials here to select digits to
get a number and then you crank here and
it adds to the accumulator down here
and you can actually move this whole
thing
[Music]
left and right a number of digits and
when you're adding it puts the numbers
down on
shifted
over so this essentially lets you
multiply by 10 100
1000 and so on
so this one doesn't directly support
multiplication but you can you can kind
of achieve it by um doing these shift
operations and additions and you can i
think you can subtract by just cranking
the other way
and what's interesting is that this is
exactly what the arithmetic logic unit
in a microprocessor does
it only does those same operations at
this old mechanical device it can add
subtract and shift to the left and right
of course this uses binary number
systems so it's it's going to shift in 2
4 8 16 and so on rather than
10 100 and so on
and of course for registers we have a
lot more registers than on a mechanical
device on risk 5 we have
32 registers
one of them is
a bit special
because it's always
zero it means whatever i write into it
i'm always going to read
um
zero out now this
sounds maybe a bit nonsensical but it's
actually if you start playing around
with risk five assembly you will find
that this is actually very practical
that you have a register that you always
know
is zero
i wish that was actually in a lot of
other architectures
when you're programming
risk five
you typically don't use those x names
for the registers you tend to use these
aliases
for the same registers and that's
because when you're
when you're programming for instance i
make implement a function that's going
to be called from a high level
programming language
and i want to be able to pass
arguments how do i do that
well you follow typically conventions
there's a binary
api
and this says that these registers from
a0
to a7 that's where you pass
your arguments
and the return values is in this a 0
that you can see here
now when you
call a function you are responsible for
restoring or making sure you don't
overwrite registers that the calling
program might be using to do different
calculations
this can be cumbersome to have to do
that for just simple calculations so
there's a convention where these t0
to t5
are
used
for uh um you don't have to preserve
those
i'm just gonna
take some water to clear my throat here
um
um yeah and then you have other
registers
like ra which turns the return address
so when i call a function before it gets
called i store where i'm currently at
in the ra register so i can easily get
back
and then you have sp which is a stack
pointer
so this is how a typical
assembly instruction looks and if you
use the high level languages this is a
bit different
we don't call these arguments we call
those operands in assembly code
this is the destination register this is
where the results get put as you can see
in the kind of comments here
in assembly code of course the operation
you do is actually a number it's an op
code but instead of remembering a number
each time we're using a mnemonic
that makes it easier to remember those
and you don't you can't typically have
sort of free number of arguments the way
you have in high-level language
and the reason for that is that these
instructions have to be encoded
into binary form into 32-bit
word so the instruction you're
performing the mnemonic is turned into
an up code which is stored in these
seven
bits here
um and then the arguments say the rd
register requires five registers so you
can see here if i just had arbitrary
number of arguments i would run out of
space
and this also tells you why typically
all most of the risk 5 instructions they
take three arguments so that you can
have the standard encoding format
and there's five bits for each of these
operands
so if you know binary that explains you
why
you can have 32 registers
so it's not actually a problem to in
principle
have enough transistors to have more
registers uh what limits the number of
registers that you can have in a cpu is
actually this you know how many bits do
i have available
to encode them
so there are other alternatives but
encodings but i'm not going to cover
that here
so what happens when you actually run an
instruction in a microprocessor so i'm
going to show you
how it basically works in a risk
processor and this illustration that i
made here is a of course a
major simplification of how a
microprocessor works a bunch of stuff
has been
thrown out
but just to be able to illustrate the
things that i'm going to talk about here
so there's
four
clock cycles required to perform an
instruction because it happens in four
separate steps
for something like a cis processor like
x86
the way it traditionally worked this
would be a lot more complex but risk has
tried to standardize into four
uh clearly defined steps in how an
instruction is performed and that has to
do with
a concept that was kind of pioneered
with risk processor which is pipelining
but i'm not going to have time to cover
that here
so the first step is fetch
and what happens then is
it's the decoder that's the boss that's
in charge and it's using these control
lines to toggle on other computational
units so it's
it's here it's toggling on the program
counter it says okay you can release
your um
your current position in memory where
the the first instruction is
and that is sent out here
to the memory to pick a memory cell and
from the memory cell you send the actual
instruction into the instruction
register
next step is the code and here
um the instruction goes into the decoder
and based on what it finds in the
instruction it's going to toggle on
different control lines it says what
what pieces inside the cpu is going to
be enabled so this is going to say what
are the two registers i'm going to pick
as input to the alu
and what operations
i'm going to enable am i going to do an
add or a shift
and so on
so it's only a third step where you're
actually executing and doing the thing
you want so say we're doing an addition
at this point we're selecting the
where the data from the two registers we
have selected goes into the alu
um and the result comes out and gets
stored in the results
register
and
the last step is the right back step
this is where
the decoder is
selecting which outputs this is what we
call a multiplexer so you can kind of
choose you know which outputs
am i sending
data to
is similar here you can choose what what
input am i taking this or this one
so here i'm selecting that it's going to
go back to a register that i selected
here so say the third register
so that will help maybe understand a bit
more how this program works given some
comments here i can kind of see what
operations it's doing so the add-i
you can see that it's um
it adds a one to x zero
but x zero is always zero
so that the result is
that you're loading a one
into x two
so this is used here in the subtract to
allow you to kind of loop through and on
each each loop through you're
subtracting one
uh one from x1 so you're always going x1
is going down
and when you're done with that
you're storing the results into this
memory address
so that is x0 which is also always zero
so it's the fourth memory address where
we're storing the results
and then blt is a branch
if less than so if x0 is less than x1
then you're going
to the beginning
and the last one is halt stops execution
so you wouldn't necessarily have to
write it like this
um
the reason i did that was because
there's no subtract immediate so
immediate is when you have encoded some
of the data inside the instruction
itself such as
one and the reason there is no subtract
immediate is that you could do
this with add immediate instead right
because i can just put a minus one there
so there's actually no need so this is
kind of how they try to think about
keeping the number instructions minimal
um you could also written it with the
pseudo instructions to make it more
clear
what your
intentions are
a little bit so
i just want to explain the when we went
through this the first time
i used the example of
um these non-immediate ones where using
two registers as input if you're using
add i then one of the arguments is not a
register it's an actual number which is
encoded in with the instruction
and then
uh we're turning the multiplex around to
say that we want to get this this one
number in from the decoder actually and
that's what's coming into the alu and
the x0 comes from here but of course
this is always zero
and then we get a result here
store word is a little bit different
also if we look at the the right back
step
so you have to imagine that now there's
been a sort of immediate calculation we
got in a result into
our multiplexer here or result register
but rather than sending it back into a
register
we're toggling the multiplexer and
saying we want to use that on the
address bus
so
this 4 plus x0
is used to pick a memory cell here where
we're storing the x
the x1 register gets stored into that
memory location
so with this background we can talk a
bit about
micro operations
which
it's kind of useful background
information to kind of cover the thing
that i think is most important with risk
file which is
how it deals with compressed
instructions and macro operations
so micro operation then you can imagine
the architecture is changed a little bit
[Music]
it's do one thing
typically in one clock cycle
and typically have one instruction turns
into multiple micro operations
or just one and risk architecture will
turn typically to one
micro operations on cisc hardware like
an x86
this can turn into many micro operations
and an interesting thing despite the
fact that they're called micro they're
actually not the instructions are not
small
actually quite
large in terms of bits it can be 100
bits or something one micro operation
so you can think of micro operations as
sort of the interface
no sorry the the part of the
implementation they're specific to the
uh micro architecture so even though you
have the same
instructions supported for different
chips
you can have different micro operations
and you have
arm chips for instance
with the same instruction set
architecture that
uh don't use
micro operations at all and then you
have high end arm chips with the same
isa but which actually has micro
operations internally
so what they actually do is normally
these these control lines right you're
you're toggling on these normally uh
when you're decoding an instruction
you are
um you know figuring out which
of these bits to to flip to to toggle on
and
with micro operations you use a decoder
to kind of can all these uh control
lines that you're toggling on so you
know you have a one when you toggle it
zero when you're not toggling and that's
why it adds up to being all these number
of bits you know that you can end up
with a 100 bits because there's so many
different parts you're going to toggle
on and off inside the
processor depending on how complex the
micro architecture is
now it doesn't make very much sense with
the architecture i just showed you at
least for for risk to have micro
operations it does make sense for a cisc
processor because it allows you to make
a cisc act a bit like a risk processor
internally for things like pipelining
but for
this to make sense for a risk processor
you have to have a super scalar
microprocessor and that means that you
have
multiple decoders that are running at
the same time
that are decoding
several operations
in parallel
and this gets put in the
micro operations buffer
and you're doing some kind of analysis
where you're checking instructions that
come after each other
are the results related to each other
if they're not so you have a multiply
and an addition
then i can run the multiply instruction
in parallel
with the addition
and so i can get more than one
instruction carried out each clock cycle
now how is this different from having
multiple cores well you've had multiple
cores you as a programmer have to see
okay you have to handle multiple threads
right to get the extra performance
with the superscalar microprocessor you
don't see multiple threads you just see
one thread that's just running faster
and this is made even faster if you have
what's called an out of order
superscalar maker processor where
you can rearrange the instructions so
that you can run them more easily in
parallel
the problem that this requires a lot of
extra silicon because you have to
arrange the instruction results back
afterwards to make sure it's not in the
wrong order
so here is the
the key thing that i think is
interesting with risk five
compressed instructions and what we call
macro up fusion
is something that has been developed
over time
and has been added to
x86 processors over time
the benefit when designing risk 5 is
that they knew about these things
already
and can take that into account
when designing the microprocessor
so if we if we
take a step back and consider uh cisc
processors like x86 complex instruction
set computers
that have variable length instructions
um
they started using micro operations
um as a way to deal with the fact that
they were getting out competed in the
90s by risk processors
and
by using micro-ops
they can kind of simulate a risk
processor internally because they they
cut up their complex instructions into
all these simple risk-like instructions
they take
that can then easily be put into a
pipeline which is really only possible
if you're dealing with
instructions that have kind of
the same number of clock cycles
well there are exceptions to to
everything but in general most of your
instructions should be similar or clock
cycles for this to work well
so you can see you get
well variable number of instructions
coming out and then you get some number
of micro operations coming out
so
this meant that
for a while cisc actually got the upper
hand
on risk
processor using micro-ops because
variable length instructions enable them
to have programs that took less space in
memory
so this means that your cache you can
utilize cache more efficiently gives you
better performance
so what's the risk counter move to this
well that is compressed instructions so
that means that
you have
two instructions compressed into a
32-bit word
so if you know the arm architecture
there is
two compressed instruction sets
thumb and thumb two
um this had to be bolted onto arm
after the fact so arm actually has to do
a mode switch and have to have separate
decoders it treats compressed
instructions as a sort of separate
instruction set architecture
um with risk five you have the benefits
that this could be designed in from the
start
so the the format and the instructions
and so on has taken that into
consideration that they should support
compressed instructions it's just an
extension if you have that extension you
can support it and it's actually very
cheap to implement it's only 400 logical
gates like ands or nand and so on gates
that you need to implement compressed
instructions and it's not like a sip
operation this is
the decompression is very fast
but of course it's not
it's not magic
you can't take every possible
instruction you have and compress them
so instead of how it works is you take
the most commonly used instructions that
most affect your performance
and
you have compressed versions of them but
only if you have two operands
why can't you have
why can't you have three operands
when uh you have a 16-bit instruction
can you think about that
so
with three operands because there's five
bits per operand you would consume 15
bits just to specify the operands
and you only have 16 bits so that would
leave you one bit to say what operation
you're doing so that's not going to be
enough
here's something that seems a bit
counterintuitive
and that is macro operation fusion
this is sort of the opposite of what
microops is about you're taking in uh
fairly simple instructions and you're
getting more complex ones out so it's
kind of like taking risk instructions in
and you're getting cis constructions out
how does that make any sense why do you
want to do that well it's actually intel
that discover this
that
some of the instructions are just so
simple
that they're just kind of wasting
resources that you can actually see that
is actually a possibility to encode more
functionality within one micro operation
so the idea with micro up fusion is that
you take instructions that are just too
simple and turn them into instructions
that are more complex but not so complex
that they are like a cyst construction
so the benefit of that is of course what
the size performance is you know how
many micro operations that you do so by
having fewer micro operations
uh you can
get
better performance so yeah to clarify
these macro operations they do get
turned into micro operations later
just to show you here so this is what i
think is sort of the risk 5
genius
so instead of having all these complex
instructions supported
you can just put together two simple
instructions
in any kind of combination and those two
simple instructions are kind of like
um
a complex instruction so you have two
compressed uh so four instructions here
that are just compressed it looks like
there's three instructions coming in
they get decompressed
into five instructions and then you do
macro up fusion and you get three macro
operations
and these micro these macro operations
can then be decoded and turned into
micro operations so the end effect here
is
for you're just
in terms of memory usage in the cache
you're only paying as if it was three
instructions and in terms of execution
instructions to execute even if it's
five that went in
so
to give a concrete example of how this
works
um
here's
a
[Music]
some c code very simple thing
get index you're getting an element
at index i in an array
and this is used often as an example of
why you should have complex addressing
modes
which is kind of used as a criticism
typically against risk five because they
don't have that
so if you want to perform this with
intel um
x86 the code would look something like
this i'm not going to cover that one
i'll i'll talk more about the r one
instead so an arm
arm is not sort of as risk as something
like risk five arm has instructions that
look a bit
risk-like and one example is kind of
addressing modes this is ldr's load
register
and it takes
all this to compute an address in memory
to load
you can see an explanation of it here so
lsl is logical shift left so you're
shifting two bits to the left so you're
the same as multiply by four and why is
that well it's because
r1
that is the second argument this one
r0 that is the first argument
so
because this is an integer integers are
in 4 byte boundaries so that's why
you're multiplying with a 4.
so you're
you're taking the the offset for the
index and you're adding that to the base
address of the array and then you get
and then you're looking that up in
memory and storing r0 r0 is where you
return values for a function
and then find your bx is
branch and link and then the lr is the
link register the register that stores
the return address
now we can compare this with risk five
this doesn't look so good for risk five
it's twice as many instructions because
you only have these very simple
instructions
so you're going to take twice the memory
it's going to uh twice the sort of the
time to execute
in theory
so the first thing we're going to do
here is shift
left logical immediate
that's this operation shifts the a1
register so the a1 if you remember
that's the
second argument of function a0 is the
first argument so that this is the the i
we're multiplying that by four
then we're adding that to
um
the the array pointer address
then when we have this new address we're
using that
with a load operation load word
where we're using that as input and then
finally we're returning
red is actually a
pseudo instruction so it's actually
short for this
jump and link register
it actually does two operations the
first is a no operation because it goes
to x0 so only care about the second part
which is
to take the the ra register plus
the offset there 0 and put that into the
program counter and that has the effect
of jumping in your program
but here is where
the solution for risk five
because
let's see it
now what you'll notice here is that they
use
two of the arguments are the same or two
of the operands are the same
that gives an opportunity to compress
these instructions and that's what you
can do now
you wouldn't have to put this this c dot
is typically just written as to indicate
this is a compressed instruction when
you're actually writing assembly you
don't have to do this the assembler will
able to figure that out for you
but that means that you can compress all
of these instructions
because you really only need two
operands
so you can think about it the operations
are happening as you can see described
here in the comments
um
so this means that it's uh
the the amount of memory it's going to
take is going to be exactly the same as
for arm and intel
but it's still
for instructions to execute
so how do we deal with that
or we can do macro fusion
so with macrofusion you have the rule
for this to work the destination
register
of two consecutive instructions
these two they have to be the same
and so
that is possible with add and load word
so we can fuse those together now adds
lw that's just a made up name it does
there's no instruction called that
it's just to represent a fused a macro
operation
so you can see now that
that operation does
all of these things
and at this point we
we now have only three micro operations
inside the architecture that we actually
have to um
execute
uh
so that's only one more than on x86 and
arm
but can we do better
um we can from a
from the point of view of micro
operations
so if we rearrange this and we're using
um the t0 register it's not the t0 is
important but i just rearranged it a bit
so that
we have three instructions that are
using the same destination
address
and that allows us to do a macro of
fusion of three of three instructions
the downside of doing this approach is
that you can see that
we only have those three instructions
which we can use to compress form
because now we're having a different
operand
for all three
so this gives us
again i'm just made up a name um
slli add lw as a the macro
the fused macro operation
but it's interesting if you compare that
to arm
it's essentially doing exactly the same
as this arm ldr at this point
it's doing the
um multiplying to get the the index base
offset it's adding the um
the base address and doing the memory
lookup all in one instruction
so
with this we have the same number of
micro ops but of course we require 10
bytes rather than 8.
so that is very close
but of course
this is just one example
what if you're looking at a more more
realistic programs
where this is hap where there's a lot of
different instructions like this
what is the end result can actually risk
match
arm and x86 in terms of a density of
instructions and the numeral
instructions that have to be executed
and there are some guys that actually
investigated this there's a paper
the title is written down here it's
belong the renewed case for
reduced instruction set computer
avoiding
isa bloat with macro fusion for risk
five
so what this has done is it's normalized
on the number of instructions
for
x8664 that has to be
computed for all these different
programs that you see underneath here
and then they compare it with the number
of instructions for other architectures
and with the number of macro ops
for when using compressed instructions
on macro fusion for risk five and the
number of micro ops in x60
x
so the reason you can find the micro
operations is actually that um
x86 processors have these micro up
counters internally so you can actually
uh
count that
so this is not a
totally great comparison because
um
the arm numbers right are not the actual
micro operations
but you can already see here that if you
compare the
the purple and the yellow
that's um
that are most comparable that risk five
is actually looking pretty good here
and what about the size of the programs
you can see here
with compressed instructions risk is
in most cases actually be eating the
other architectures it's spending less
memory despite having
so much simpler instruction sets than
the others despite the others having a
lot more complex instructions they can
do more
they still end up using more space
and
to be able to make a more accurate
comparison
um
what the people that wrote this paper
here did was
they
um they looked they analyzed they use
tools to run over the
arm code and
they made some heuristics or guesses
about the number of micro operations
that each instruction would
uh turn into and that's because there
are kind of rules of what you minimum
will have to do if you're doing an
operation that causes rights to multiple
registers
it's going to have to be
a micro operation for every register
right
so by using that as a kind of heuristic
they compare them that you can see here
in the graphs that are highlighted
that risk actually narrowly has fewer
micro operations that it has to perform
than the competitors
a little bit caveat here is that
um
i'm not sure whether they have taken
into account the fact that you can do
macro up fusion
on x86 and possibly an arm i'm not quite
sure
but this looks very promising
for risk five
so
so in total um
what i think is
great about this is that you can see you
can have these sort of you can have a
cake and eat it too you can have a
simple instruction set that you can
easily learn but you're not actually
sacrificing performance to do that and
this has only been possible because they
could design this knowing that you can
have compressed instructions and macro
fusion
okay
so thank you let's see what is the
time like do we have time for some
questions
yes
is
um
yeah well um
i mean they've always been able to do
that right
um
but
intel has found this to be useful they
were the ones who started doing it
um
yes but i mean in principle they could
have they could have added instructions
that com that are similar to um
uh
to these fusion operations um
i think the
the downside with
uh adding lots of ins because you can
imagine this you create a an explosion
of permutations if you know every
two or three instructions that you can
put together in different ways
that's going to require
quite a lot of different instructions to
the code so you're you're spending a lot
of your encoding space and this is one
of the things that
risk five
designers consider it important is
not to paint yourself into a corner by
by using up all your encoding space
that's what arm did for instance uh
originally with their 32-bit
architecture so they couldn't add um
compressed instructions after the fact
that they spent their encoding space and
they want this to be a long-lived
instruction set architecture what is
going to be efficient in
10 years to do we don't know maybe macro
fusion
is replaced with something else
we don't know so if we kind of
preemptively try to be smart about this
and add lots of instructions
uh we might have add instructions that
are not going to have value in the
future so that's why they're they're
trying to do as much as possible with
this few instructions to be
future proof
so for an architecture that's mainly
meant for industry like x86 and arm
i can agree that's
what you're suggesting is probably would
make sense but
it might not make sense for something
that is meant to be more academic and
longer
term existence
yeah
okay
yeah so
you can add the extra instructions and
that can just be with the whole
processor
so
uh
yeah well if you take for instance um
if you take the vector instructions
extension that adds a bunch of special
vector registers and then there's regis
there's instructions for moving things
between the vector instructions
and
the general purpose registers and
possibly you can have
i mean i know that on
arm for instance that
the lower part of the vector registers
are the same as your um floating point
registers
you could possibly do something like
that um
so this is actually
part of the benefit that people
see i think with this is that
you can kind of merge the accelerator
part with a more sort of general purpose
kind of
cpu um
yeah so that that's that's they're quite
flexible i mean if you look at the
um
this minion and maxine
chips you have the maxims which are
quite general purpose but those minion
ones right they have just
um you know the base
the base instruction set implemented and
the rest are kind of these
uh vector extensions and that's
all in one chip so it's a very it isn't
even though it has these risk processors
it's not really a general purpose cpu
those minions they're
special purpose chips
but when
um esperanto was designing this they
they started those miniatures where
originally were just
special purpose instructions
but they found that actually creating
you have to do these kind of general
purpose things even when you're doing
specialized hardware
and
they found that it was actually quite a
lot of work to get that right and you
didn't have the tools and so on and so
they they tested risk five and they saw
hey they've done a lot of the work for
us we're just gonna build on that so i
think
that's probably what many hardware
makers are gonna
increasingly see
any uh
other questions
okay well thank you
[Applause]
you